good morning bachelor nation thank you
so much for joining us at roses and Rose
day live i have wells Adams here I am so
glad you're here on the morning of the
finale I know I mean and you're not at
all hungover even though you went to
Dave Matthews Band concert last night
[Laughter]
guys Wells is an absolute pro he was the
bartender all season long so we get to
ask him about last night's crazy episode
or we had multiple traumatic breakups I
felt and we're gonna tease the finale
tonight we have the Paradise finale
footage we have the tell-all so so much
is happening as we wrap up the season of
bachelor in paradise want to know what
you think any questions or comments you
have about the episodes or farewells
leave them on our socials let's just
dive right into all the drama I want to
start by saying how upset was Sarah with
Kendall breaking up with Joe I saw this
on insta stories last night your girl
Sarah Hyland was not happy to Kendall
and Joe parted ways so the problem that
Sarah now lives in is that she gets like
all the behind-the-scenes stuff while we
are filming I'm not really allowed to
talk to anybody but like you got to talk
to somebody I sure and so when we were
filming the show I would she would call
me and she like what's going on and I'm
like you don't even know so like she got
to hear like a little bit now she
watches it play out and she's like
getting she knew how annoyed I was
during the time and then watching it
back she's like oh I get it well it was
such an out of left field and I also
felt hard to understand reasoning
breakup so when you're frustrated when
you're kind of seeing it all go down
there what was going through your mind
where you confused like why do you think
that that relationship ended I don't
know like it to me it never seemed like
Kendall was all in with Joe and Joe was
always 100% in and he was so patient
with her and there were a couple of
times where I was I wanted to shake him
and be like Joe I think the problem is
is that she doesn't feel challenged by
you he needed to play a little more
hard-to-get he had to and but I I had a
feeling that it was gonna go down
the way it did I kind of wish it went
down the other way where we're you know
Joe was just like like he never gets mad
the only time you got really mad was
with Leo you know and even then I was
like it's not like you've really changed
or raised the volume of his voice I
think Joe's a pretty even guy but I do
love Joe I do and that's a thing like
Sarah I don't think she's really mad at
Kendall right I think she's mad at the
situation because everyone loves Joe so
much so much and it's been good to see
him I did not think the Bachelorette was
the environment for him he kind of got
lost in the mix but paradise where it's
a little more chill where there's more
time because he's not a super talkative
guy I mean I feel like on
bachelor/bachelorette you really have to
put yourself out there but on paradise
you can like chill and chat more and it
seemed like a better place for Joe but
here's the thing the reason why I love
Joe so much is there's a lot of people
that walk in to that place and sit at my
bar and for lack of a better term like
they're not there for the right reasons
they're like I want to be on TV I want
to say some stupid stuff so I get a lot
of airtime are people saying this are
you getting the spot yeah like Leo was a
good example of that I came in there and
he was like wanting to mix it up cause
he's starting stuff yeah and it was like
this is so inauthentic you know and I
think people watch the show and they're
like that person's not real because you
can like see that you know authenticity
like it just bleeds through the screen
and Joe is the most authentic being like
I don't know if I should be yeah I'm
gonna go home now
you know everyone could like relate to
him because I tell everyone would be in
that situation if you words like a
normal person walking in there yeah not
like someone being like I'm gonna say
some crazy things like sweep my hair
over and like get a bunch of airtime so
that's why I love Joe he was like the
most real guy there and that's why I
like really wanted him to be the
bachelor I think it would be like a
really authentic experience because he
really probably shouldn't be the
bachelor you know interesting I loved
everybody rallying behind Joe to be
bachelor cuz it was like this guy from
night one and it was such a fun story
but I will say having interviewed him
and I noticed a big difference when I
interviewed him at Mantella versus
interviewing him after the Paradise
tell-all he was a lot more comfortable
that's when I wondered with him
bachelor I'm like is he comfortable
enough to literally like as the lead you
have to talk so much talk out your
feelings and I wondered would we get
enough from him because we experienced
with Arie what it's like when someone
doesn't have a lot to say so that's all
I would say for Jo is I almost thought
it's like you need a few more seasons of
reality TV under your belt because even
the lead usually has a whole season of
bachelor/bachelorette to get used to
being on camera Jo had one night so if
he'd gone from that to bachelor he would
have been like like deer in the
headlights I thought good yeah yeah I
will say like in the beginning we were
all like dude you got to talk say
something yeah and then he got he got
better at it but like I don't like the
idea of like a seasoned vet might be
really good
reality TV because then it comes across
as almost like acting you know no but
then with Arie it was like he hadn't
been on TV for so long and I felt that
hurt him because he just literally
wasn't used to the environment and so
even if he was having authentic feelings
we weren't like seeing and hearing them
as much I mean we're really digging into
this a dumpster fire that was a trash
pile set ablaze rocketed into space it
was bad comments coming in Debbie says
Joe is too good for Kendall I don't know
if I feel that way I think Joe is too
good for everybody
oh wow well guys by the way we have an
exclusive sneak peek of tonight's
episode up a TT online.com right now
Kendall visiting Joe so we have to see
what happens because I do not think that
this love story is completely over
there's a clip up on our website you can
go check it out she actually goes and
visits him after filming the show ended
what could you tease for us about that I
don't know so you know more than I do
oh I guess I do because after show ended
like I didn't talk to them you know okay
I talked to Joe that night when he left
I was really upset really I really liked
Joe and like wanted to hang out with him
and when he just left and didn't say
goodbye to anybody I was like what a
jerk do you think he was really that
upset yeah I think he was upset yeah I
understood but I was like I where's my
hug you know we got a hug the
bartender's please don't tip them with
affection
well you mentioned Leo and I want to ask
you about that because it was really
wild to see Leo on paradise versus Leo
on The Bachelorette because I'm bachelor
he was kind of this like funny a side
guy and then on Paradise I mean I will
say I watched it and I think sometimes
tell me how you feel but I think
sometimes people go on the show and like
you said they they're there to like stir
stuff up and then the way they come
across on screen is insane or
everybody's like he's acting nuts I felt
like he was just trying to create like
he's an actor he has an IMDB page what
do you think yeah I think he was acting
and I don't think he's gonna get a lot
of work in this town cuz I mean he was
doing a very good job of it it was just
weird like the whole thing came across
is just odd
yeah and they cut a lot of stuff
actually like there was this one day I
think they showed it like we're Kevin
and Astrid like he like made up a wooden
TV and they're like Netflix and chilled
and watch the sunset but they cut this
thing we're like Leo went over there and
like grabbed the TV and like threw it in
the sand and was like snitches don't get
to watch TV and we were all like what
are you doing like what is this and I
don't know like the whole thing was just
super forced and I don't know like the
one thing that like I always it never
ceases to amaze me that like the macho
guy usually isn't the winner in the
bachelor world and I think that like
that guy has always been an alpha and
he's probably never lost at anything and
then like going on that show and kind of
looking like an idiot I think his ego
was bruised and then he didn't know what
to do is like fight or flight and then
he just like went off the rails I think
that was it but like losing out to a guy
like Joe who's like such a sweet guy I'm
sure he's like I don't get it I don't
get what this whole thing is how am i
losing due to like a grocery store
cousin oh yeah like interesting well I
did wonder in that situation and I don't
know how much you want to say or can
tell me but look of course we all know
like this is a reality show it's
produced
I wondered how much her producers
encouraging Leo to act like this how
much is he acting on his own because
when the fight happened you kind of saw
the fourth wall got broken a little bit
you saw the producers rush in and be
like whoa whoa whoa tell us tell me like
how much you think that was Leo on his
own and and what everybody's reaction to
was when that fight happened yeah I I
will defend the producers to like the
end of the earth I think it's so easy to
be
like oh it's edited that way or like
they told him to do that there's not a
whole lot of that like the Edit or the
producing I will say I don't even mind
if there is some of that like you've got
a producer's TV show yeah I know but
like the editing and the producing of
that show happens just like with the
scenarios that people are put into if
you put a guy like that and a guy like
Joe in the same room together and like
they're fighting over one girl like
there's going to be something it's just
natural I don't think they were like hey
Leo go be a weirdo and like the one
thing I will say about the fight though
they they edited it a little bit to not
how I remember it
I remember Leo said that called him
yeah and then Joe got upset and Joe was
like say it to my face
and he said it again and then Joe pushes
him and I think that was the moment Leo
realized oh this isn't like this is real
oh my god all of a sudden became like
not 6'5 in like Jason's like oh god this
is a real thing and that's when Eddie
the producer who like played football
cow-like came in and tackled him really
yes and was he just assured right out
nobody said goodbyes to Leo or anything
I get well I remember when I was
watching it he said say it to my face I
felt like Leo was even surprised by that
cuz he kind of like said it really
quickly like grocery store and that
looks like he didn't know how to he
didn't really own saying it to his face
as much as he maybe could have yeah and
the one thing I will say like Leo is a
big dude but Joe is a big guy too
yeah like he's tall really tall I don't
know if you notice his hands are like
banana hands they're huge so I remember
like when that happened I was like I'd
watch this fight I'd pay for this some
people I mean do you think that
Kendall's feelings for Leo were that
legit or was she just sort of freaked
out by the seriousness of Joe and kind
of scrambling what they had talked
before the show from what I understood
her and Leo yeah I got that vibe and I
wondered because she kept saying that
Leo seemed like a more realistic fit
like literally he lives in LA and she
lives in yeah
and I get that like in Kendall's defense
everyone talks before the show and as
you should if you're gonna go like cuz
the odds of really finding someone to
get engaged are pretty small if you
don't know anybody so if you have the
opportunity to like kind of feel people
out beforehand then it's I think it's a
good idea and it helps the process
totally right like it is 28 days it's
quick and they cut this one short that's
like a little thing that people don't
realize but filming short you mean oh
yeah there was like they stopped early
we were supposed to like that's why in
that episode and Chris comes in he's
like Venice suits tomorrow everyone's
like wow it seemed quick yeah we all
thought we all thought we were gonna do
like a whole another week and I don't
know if it was because they had enough
stuff or because they just wanted to
keep everyone on their toes but everyone
was expecting it to be a little bit
longer but like you know people do talk
beforehand and I think that she had a
conversation with Leo and I was like
yeah this would be this could this could
work in the real world and then it could
not work it did not work interesting so
in that being kind of cut short how do
you think that did that really like
bring things to light would things have
been different if there was another week
yeah I don't know like the one thing
that you have to expect every week is
that you don't know what to expect you
know like Robby Hays might come in
exactly let's be real like that was
purely for Robin Jordan I mean well it
had to happen so yeah I think that I
think you're right like I think it's
screwed with people's minds and
timelines I think that probably really
messed with Kevin and Astrid I think
that Kevin probably wanted another week
and didn't get it and kind of like
freaked out well let's dig into that one
because that was the gonna be next I
felt like it really was an episode of oh
my god these people are breaking up and
maybe this the shortening of it all is
is kind of helping us understand it
Kevin when he said I'm 80% I'm 20% and
then were you blown away that that
happened in the moment I was interviewed
I don't know bites some outlet but like
before the season started and I was like
there's one breakup that like I couldn't
believe
happened and like affected me like on a
personal level because they were they
were like the the Derek and Taylor of
last season we're like they got no
airtime because they were so boring
because they were so perfect for each
other you know and when that happened I
was I wasn't in on the beach when they
broke up so watching it back I was the
exact same way when I heard about it
that Ashford was which is like you've
gotta be kidding me what are you talking
what's happening how did this happen and
I I don't know and also in my mind I'm
thinking like what are you doing this is
the hottest chick you are ever going to
get gorgeous she's so I've interviewed
before she's so grounded so new smart
like super cool yeah I I love Ashton I
was like what is going on and I I think
that that was a huge mistake I think in
Kevin's defense due to suffering like
Bachelor PTSD he Ashley gets engaged
there right in front of his eyes and
then like I know he was on bachelor
canada and he like got engaged there and
so i think that he did bring that up
like it's you have to understand where
I'm coming from and this has happened to
me yeah bachelor PTSD BTS D yes bachelor
traumatic stress disorder I mean do you
think or did you get to talk to either
of them right after that breakup did you
get the sense I felt like Kendall had a
kind of an immediate sense of confusion
and regret in the limo
yeah with Kevin and Astrid what were
they like right after did you say your
goodbyes to them I don't even remember
now you're like Iowa Street I talked to
him I talked to them like after the show
like cos Astrid and I were friends from
from before Astrid was supposed to be on
paradise like last season and she was
just like she was just hurt and I think
she was just like what happened like you
know well as you know more than most
people they're like what happened I was
like honestly everyone was just like
what what is going on like I think
everyone assumed that that was like
fantasy suite number one
yeah couple especially because he'd said
some things at certain points like you
know I'm 34 I know what I want he's not
like a 24 year old that you get
sometimes where yeah
I mean even though he's been through a
lot I think that has also hopefully
helped him know what he wants
but I also will say that you know
they're both gonna be at the tell-all so
you're gonna see some stuff happen
tonight you guys
lots of Wells has a very good analysis
of the macho male in a bachelor
environment Loras
Victoria we did want to ask you this so
we'll get to your question here Victoria
she says what do you think of Colton as
the new bachelor
I think that he will be a really good
bachelor agree but tell me why what
makes a good bachelor for you well I
think you gotta be able to cry I think
that he will be wait is that really why
we were so close the contract they're
like cry right now do some Visine help I
think he'll be a really good bachelor I
think that I think that maybe a vCard
will be dropped in a fantasy suite which
I'm like for the first time everything
that's pretty great I think that middle
America will love him he's such like a
good like former football player a
charity yeah exactly a lot of dog pics
on Instagram so I think he'll be great
to be honest with you I think I think of
the three guys that everyone was talking
about I think he is the best option so
I'm kind of reading between the lines
what you're saying which I agree with
you think he's the best option to make a
good TV show yes I agree and like and
also remember what the TV show is
supposed to do you're supposed to
basically get a marriage at of the thing
I think that I don't really know the two
other dudes but I do know Colton and I
think he really does want to find that
person and I think he really does want
to like settle down and have kids and
stuff and so I think you'll get that out
of him more so than maybe the two other
guys okay interesting I will say you
know I think Jason was a little older
which made me think like he's ready and
Blake is like very emotional which made
me think he's ready but I just think
this was not a year for me where you
know I felt like last year people were
really upset it wasn't Peter yeah
Jason and Blake I kind of felt like I'd
be okay with any of them and I think
Colton has I mean how do you pass up the
first ever virgin bachelor buddy no he's
not the first ever well Sean Lowe was a
born-again oh he was real after 24
waiting till marriage Colton is real
listen I think that I think Colton will
be a mazing bachelor I really do
well we're excited I agree okay Sammy
says what do you think of Chris intro I
didn't maybe eyebrow Sammy are you
enlightening me here did Chris Harrison
introduce Angela and clay outside of
paradise is that how they ended up
together I just saw it like on now
together which is great yeah they look
really cute
very sexy couple I'm in I didn't
understand that between her and Eric it
was very confusing yeah I I think that
Eric is like much as I think he's a
mature guy and a good friend I think
Eric is not ready for a really like I
don't think he knows what he wants that
was very confusing reasoning to me there
are people that are really good at
giving you advice but are terrible at
taking their own advice I always said
he's that guy he's like like he's like a
sounding board for everyone else he Oh
like he's that like inspirational
Instagram guy yeah that like is so
annoying but like you're like you're
right but yeah like and Bibiana exist
they're the exact same person and they
can call you out on your own stuff but
then it's like they're struggling yeah
yes like you're giving such good advice
but you're just not taking it maybe Eric
and Viviana together you guys I don't
know I don't hate that right it's not a
bad idea they're both like we're trying
to figure out those out and we can
advise each other actually on our own
relationship I'm gonna make it work
I love Bibiana okay I'm real quick
Annelise and Camille can I just get your
read on analyse who she was in here and
I think she is so sweet but man I gotta
use the word delusional she seems not
grounded in what in where her heads at
in this relationship and in her
awareness of where his head is at in
this relationship yeah it's a little
cringe-worthy
yeah in Anneliese defense
Camille's leading her on is he I think
so like hard for me to tell he's very
monotone he is so he's a
great guy so boring like I'm like what's
behind the eyes I can't get a read here
okay yeah I think like I don't know you
saw last night where he was talking to
the guys and he was like I really don't
know so do you think he's a great guy
you just a great guy is he a great guy
yeah I don't know all right
let's backtrack on that just a touch
maybe I'm not sure I said he was boring
okay I don't yeah I don't know if he's I
hate god I think that he was leading her
on okay and I do think she is delusional
but I think that her beliefs are rooted
in a little bit of truth like he is
saying the right things to her and he
had a total he had so many outs and he
didn't take him and I don't know what
the real reason was is it like I want to
actually get engaged I don't know if I
believe that do I just want to like
stick around on TV as long as I possibly
can I kind of believe that what's the
motivation there I have to imagine that
everybody's not getting that great of a
day rate I don't know it's not like
we're what is them is if when you do say
like you said there are people who come
and they're like they want to be on TV
they want to stick around is it I hope I
get more followers I don't think it's
the money like what's is it a desire for
fame yeah I don't know I think it's
probably a combination of all those
things it's also a free vacation Oh true
and so like once you kind of like get
settled into like the cameras like just
following you around or like you let
those things dissolve from your reality
then it's just like a free vacation with
like really good food and like funny
people and I think that was like one of
the reasons like I want to go be the
bartenders because it's so much fun just
like experience all in summer camp kind
of exactly it's adult summer care there
we go all right bachelor in paradise
summer camp I have a really big bone to
pick with Robbie Hayes showing up last
night there you know what here's what
I'll say I've loved this season and I
think it's way better than last season
and I don't blame anyone for that it was
hard to rebound what we'd come from but
I love a couple things like one I feel
like the women are enjoying themselves
and I love a couple of guys who are
really invested like Jordan and Joe are
so all-in and I love
watching them yes and I love that
everybody's like hey we're all just here
to have fun for the most part but there
have been a lot of really late arrivals
that at this point in the game are
feeling disingenuous to me like I didn't
need I get what you're saying Robbie and
Jordan we wanted to see that but like we
needed we needed to do but I didn't need
Robbie to even say I'm here to find
somebody like yeah when people are
saying I love you and about to go to the
fantasy suites and then Robbie shows up
like it felt very I don't know it's a
weird glitch in the show because you got
to keep bringing people on but at that
time it's just like really late in the
game there's nothing you can really do
so I think that the best thing to do is
like lean towards the comedy of it and
having Robbie and Jordan meet and have
like the walk-off and all that kind of
stupid stuff yeah that's like the only
way to play it I guess but Robbie Robbie
almost didn't show up he missed his
flight to get there that tracks for
Robbie if you watch these shows you know
he's been supposed to have been here a
couple times and he's missed it that
tracks okay I'm actually I'm not sure I
I do love Robbie I don't know if I've
ever like gone to an event or had to be
it somewhere where he has made his
flight okay he's always but he is that
guy okay and I'm always like that change
I was like 200 bucks I really did make
your flight so yeah he was he was late
like a day lay so we are supposed to get
more of the Robbie Jordan thing I think
and I remember the producers being like
once again Robbie booking Southwest next
time no change fees Cathy says yes Kevin
and Astrid needed more time that's what
was missing and she believes that they
could work outside of paradise well
again the tell-all is tonight you guys
mixed in with the fantasy footage and
fantasy suites footage and you go see
very critical question Chris Harrison
has worn a jacket so many times this
season and I don't understand it
how is so hot there how was he wearing
these jackets at the Rose ceremonies I
don't think he sweats it's yeah I don't
know if he does I'm not sure if he's
human he might be as he is a superhero
he also like lived
the king of Bachelor right yeah and so
like he gets like walked in like on like
one of those like carrying Thrones and
he's like being fanned by no shirts with
like all the branches and stuff Robbie
was supposed to be carrying if he must
yeah like you have to remember he he
just he sits like backstage or whatever
whatever you want to call it like in
like an air-conditioned room and then
when they need him they're like put on
your jacket hit your mark say like this
is the final rose of the night cash your
check go home like that say I wanted
more Chris Harrison sit-downs
I liked them on winter games like I
liked that sit down with him and Ben I
wanted a Chris Harrison Annalise sit
down because I felt he really could have
dug in there I know and like I wish that
they like Chris is always upset that
like the lack of Chris on the show and I
could now relate to it cuz I got cut out
of the show a lot did you and there was
a moment where Chris and I had like a
good conversation and I was like this
would be really funny if they show like
me making him a drink and like because
he always that kind of like makes fun of
me like you know like a big brother type
of way you know
but I feel like like to the drink for
the first time this year I'm getting so
yeah I agree with you we need more Chris
Harrison I would also love you know what
just moments like that like there was
one episode of paradise last last week
there was three hours that kind of felt
too long to me but I would watch like a
behind-the-scenes special like a little
like fun moments you missed I'd watch
that like I liked the bloopers for that
reason my only complaint if I was in the
Edit Bay is they burn a lot of time on
telling retelling the story and you're
like we're with you guys listen we know
what's going on all right
we don't need like seven people
explaining what happens you know which
they and the normal people always end up
being those people like Astrid did a lot
of retelling this season like because
she's like grounded yeah I mean I love
Jordan I do too like I think it's so
funny that people think I think that the
perception of him was that he was a
villain like going into
the edge of villain for me like I don't
think the Corinne was a villain
I think the Corinne was like kooky but
she didn't say mean things about people
and Jordan really didn't say mean things
about people but I see we were saying he
was on the edge of villains yeah people
I mean that's that's let's just call a
spade a spade like he was that guy he
was supposed to be that guy yeah like I
don't think they thought Leo was that
guy you know but the thing the truth of
the matter is like he does say like
wacky things but for the most part
everyone just loves him yeah and I was
really happy you get to see his
transformation and like falling in love
with Jenna it's like the cutest sweetest
thing in the world my heart it's again
it's like and then I've loved you've
kind of seen him in Jo form this
bromance and Jordan told me like we yeah
we were the guys who were really all-in
on these girls and like they kept going
on dates and we're just like talking to
each other and kind of bonding and you
have really seen him I just be like when
he was comforting Jenna just cuz she
felt insecure wow this is like a very
vulnerable I'm really just here to
support you moment cute he's good listen
if Jordans anything he's weirdly really
good with words you know oh I don't even
know where he comes up with I think he
goes to bed thinking of like one-liners
I think he has like a little diary he's
like and he's like a couple bartender
questions for you well as the bartender
do you did get good better at making
drinks this season did you have a
signature Welles cocktail okay so I went
and took Bart is a man of did went to
night school and I got bartending when I
was in college but like that's just
that's a wet Lights drink well well yeah
Wells liquor he never heard that yeah so
I went and took a class this year cuz I
was like I want to learn like all the
crazy fruity drinks that like would be
perfect for America yeah and so I
learned all of them I spent all this
money on this freaking bartending class
and tax write-off yeah right and then I
get there and people only drink the same
drink which is tequila soda splash pine
that's it cuz everyone is terrified of
sugars and carbs and like anything that
makes their abs not be perfect
so I was like like mouth and that's
another reason why I love Joe Joe is the
only guy
like I want to be a tank a normal human
just like pina colada everybody else
tequila water yeah exactly so I think
that what I did have everyone really
like the [ __ ] a special that was the
drink that Jorge taught me last year I
made that a lot and then I think tequila
sunrises were a thing it's all tequila
in paradise huh yeah here in Mexico by
the way so many people are social teams
just telling me so many people are
saying that they missed you and they
missed your insight so more of wells
yeah on paradise I think yeah I don't
know I might be done are you done I
wouldn't do it another season why not I
I don't know I mean I probably will go
well he was supposed to be like the the
idea was that I was supposed to be
training someone to take over like that
was was the idea that you hear so that's
we realized pretty early that like that
was never gonna be a possibility truly
let me I get the joke of she she can't
speak English but she's now spend a fair
amount of time in the States and around
english-speaking people she has to be
able to speak more English than we're
seeing on TV like even at the end of the
season it was like laughs I'm like she
knows more it's one of the other either
she's completely fluent in English and
she's just like the best Khan in the
world or yeah she just doesn't know I
don't know if she cares to learn like
she's like I'm this is working for me
yeah like this stick is good okay so it
was supposed to be that you were
training Yuki yeah realize that wasn't
gonna work yeah I think we realized
pretty early that like there would just
be a lot of wrong orders you know burn a
lot of tequila so yeah so who knows
gonna happen next year how much time are
you actually on the beach behind the bar
versus like you get to go maybe not
sittin to Chris Harrison trailer but you
get to go off the B trailer I'm there a
lot and like and they were really nice
this year about being like you can go
home if you want but I was like what I
didn't come to Mexico to like send my
hotel room oh yeah I wonder like so my
friends yeah and like I also wanna like
see what happened yeah because it's it's
I'm watching the show I'm just watching
it live you know so I was there a long
time but a lot of times they'd be like
hey we don't need you until like three
so
so I'd going at three and then and then
if I came in the afternoon that meant I
was there until like 4:00 in the morning
or two like really late in just and then
if I was there in the morning that I'd
usually bail around like six gems so it
was usually like a between an eight and
a ten-hour day that's interesting to me
to hear till four in the morning is I
actually was thinking about this season
I thought we had a lot of daylight
footage like I feel in the past we've
had maybe some more nighttime moments
some more like night vision in the bed
moments and we didn't have as much this
season was this season like big on love
but small on hookups I think there were
a lot of hookups why are we seeing I
think that they had so much stuff like
that was one thing that I do remember
people talking about being like there's
so much content and especially compared
to last year or we had like rush to
finish yeah a lot of scallop stock yeah
exactly puppets made it in the edit like
no one thought that was gonna be at home
I think they had so much so much content
and not enough like hours of TV to like
put it on like we did like this whole
Spanish quiz for a date that they cut
completely there was a bunch of stuff
yeah
it was actually really funny okay I too
like a law and like the executive
producer I was like what happened
because it was really really funny cuz
the guy who won it was Jordan the Kiwi
who doesn't know any Spanish Wow it's
like of course that like all of them
America I was gonna say he's just used
from another country and then we're well
versed in just knowing other languages
yes oh yeah that's how he so what did a
lot you talk to a lot and he said he was
like I know I can't believe they cut it
either I was like I'm hoping he said I'm
hoping that we can put it like on the
internet or something yeah because it
was really really fun I'm sorry if like
I spoiled it a favor it's okay now we're
excited for it yeah like him winning it
was really that's how he got the date to
with Cassandra like on the beach and
stuff
there were even moments where like when
Jubilee was sent home it was sort of
like at the top of the episode we just
got some flashbacks oh did you like so
Jubilee left this morning like oh we're
not even seeing all the exits yeah there
was a lot of good stuff so much stuff
did you believe like was her exit just I
don't know not she had like a whole
about-face where she was like really
excited to be there and then all of a
sudden was like I gotta go
a lot of you guys are saying Jordan and
Jo
or your favorites I agree and so many
people saying they wanted more of Wells
and Yuki okay we have to wrap up here
but I got a dig in to your life outside
of Paradise which I have to say though
that your real life seems pretty great
lately yeah yeah it's good it's like
paradise I mean you've been living in LA
for about a month now yep moved in with
your lovely girlfriend Sarah Hyland
I don't even it's like how happy are you
guys like literally last night she takes
you to see Dave Matthews we're watching
you guys watch paradise on Instagram if
you haven't seen it there is a moment
that will melt your heart where Sarah is
reviewing the show and Wells reaches
over and fixes her head and my heart
just like how happy are you in the
defense of that one thing we were a bit
over-served last night that's why I said
well I'll have some water for you here
today maybe a loaf of bread
I'm so happy like it's just so fun like
it's like that Garth Brooks song you
know like it's like that you think you
want something and then you don't get it
but that's not really what you needed
you know and they did these these crazy
shows and and then all of a sudden like
I get this amazing relationship out of
it like I could have never imagined that
that was like the path I was gonna I was
going to go down but like I'm so
grateful for all of it like Chris
Harrison you miss that's one thing that
you guys missed was that I walk down the
stairs and I meet Chris and Chris is
like you're welcome for your girlfriend
sees coach it's so true you know like if
I hadn't done the show and and and met
Chris and all those people like I would
have never had the opportunity to like
meet this amazing woman so I'm in I won
I won the show let's be fair you know
I'm I'm like dude I'm glad you moved in
together and lock it down just because
you this is like lock it in the ring on
the finger and just lock that in and
never let it go cuz she's so freaking
awesome she is awesome
yeah and I mean the thing is though I
know you guys like know each I feel like
you guys are such you've always told me
you're like just the same goofy person
and you know each other so well but in
moving in together you certainly may be
like see have you learned anything new
about her or have you been like oh you
load the dishwasher different than me
like what are you seeing about each
other like I saw an interview she did
where she was like wells is more anal
than I am about cleaning which is very
very true
yeah like like she'll like wash a dish
and like leave it in the sink and I'm
like it's so close to the dishwasher why
did you just do that one more step but
actually it's it's been weirdly perfect
like there's been no real issues we were
all scared about the dogs meeting
because that's a weird thing for and
they're big dogs and that went really
well yeah it's been it's been like it's
been perfect it's been great
can I ask you how you know like when you
found someone who's this amazing enough
for you to move across the country like
what about Sarah makes you know I'm
getting in a truck moving across the
country for this girl this is special
it's so funny sunday will be our
one-year anniversary of the day we met
and we were talking about today when we
were I was watching the end of the
episode because we passed out before we
finished and and Jordan said this thing
was at the moment I saw you like I knew
and and I was like that was the same for
me like the moment like when I met you
that day I was like oh yeah this is this
is gonna be it so so he was the night
before the Emmy party and that was the
day that I knew that I had to move to LA
this is gonna be it like oh yeah for
sure for sure for sure sure I love this
so much because I remember meeting you
at Jojo Fletcher's firehouse date where
you'd been overheated so much that you
almost passed out and like what a
journey you hath been on in the show so
she's the one I love it last question
for you I guess if you're you know it
and like you guys are in this what would
you tell other people about like kind of
what to look for in a relationship what
have you learned about what makes your
relationship work I think especially for
me you need to be ready for that you
know I think that it's so easy and if
you watch The Bachelor people are like
I'm really ready to like what you're not
really ready you're 24 years old you
know and I think that there came a point
in my life where I was like I really do
want like this I don't want to be single
anymore this isn't fun for me I think
you have to be emotionally ready for
that and I think that's number one and
then I think you just need to find like
the person that is that complements you
the best
it's Sara's after me because we're both
like huge dorks we have similar
interests like our brands are the same
right like dogs
Jose tacos getting drunk and watching
The Bachelor would you I know she's a
fan and here's the thing like we saw
Ashley and Jared get engaged have you I
mean how much of a fan is she like would
you like propose to her on reality TV no
no like we're not going down that road
man have you talked about a time line
like hang on how long you gonna live
together free take things to the next
level I don't know wait and see Wow
tomorrow on Instagram live and of course
you know you have so much going on
between your bartending duties your dog
carrying duties but your podcast you're
still doing that while you're out here
in LA like what's gonna happen with all
that yeah I still work for I heart doing
the shows that I did in Nashville just
out here still doing podcast with brandy
your favorite thing I think I might do
another podcast with a different reality
TV show it's a show that was very
popular and then went away and now is
coming back Jersey Shore the hills I
don't know okay
so that might happen and then who knows
what else is gonna happen okay amazing
well from the heat of the firehouse date
to the heat of Mexico and like here's
your life man it's awesome love having
you in thank you so much for your
insight this was so perfect for the
in-between finale episodes morning guys
if you don't follow Welles unsocial man
are you missing some fun drunken nights
that end within and out between him and
Sara yeah so absolutely do it and thank
you guys so much for watching with us
all season long
tonight is the final final final episode
of this wonderful fifth season of
bachelor in paradise and it's gonna be
crazy the tell-all stuff I was at the
taping you guys it's nuts oh oh I got to
do something that I've never got to do
before which was I got to watch the
maybe engagements maybe not engagements
and I got to hear it this year like they
let me listen like during filming yes
cuz like because Yuki and I got to watch
and we're like it was like really
beautiful right there's one moment where
I I actually cried because the one time
I actually cried in the bachelor
a really really good moment that's gonna
happen so we're gonna have to I don't
have to talk to you off camera because I
actually cried and I wonder if it was
the same moment because I have to say
like I don't as much as I love these
shows I don't cry watching them at night
Wow okay they say that's hard guys so
watch tonight and everybody we will have
a new episode of roses and roses a recap
up for you tomorrow morning and as
always just keep sending your comments
and laura says OMG wells and sarah are
so cute with five O's agree have a great
night everybody thank you bite
[Music]
you